I did not realize that until I came over
here I did the the Bret the breakfast
which mark mark was pointing out what is
it every show every show has the word
breakfast dinner yep breakfast is that
what it is beggars radio breakfast radio
breakfast three radio breakfast five big
deal I did a BBC Breakfast and they were
asking about the sensor is on Family Guy
and I said I said well you know
sometimes I get a little pissed with us
in these guys
[Laughter]
explanation you you watch how many guy a
lot don't you
I did with my son yeah every time I come
on this show I'm like [ __ ] do we take a
jab at that guy you introduced your kids
quite young to Family Guy didn't you I
thought it's a cartoon I didn't know I
mean I'm like okay well let me at least
see some of his work cuz you don't
probably gonna make this movie together
so I they send me the one hundred and
fiftieth anniversary episode so I start
watching with my kids and I'm telling
you we are digging it so hard you got
Stewie's locked in the safe with the
girl now I start drinking and all this
stuff that he throws up and Yanks him
eat it and then he poops that his diaper
and he makes him clean it my kids and I
are crack up my wife comes running in
going what's going on what's going on I
want to be a part of this much that oh
my god
I'm in trouble for too
[Music]
here with the share don't be discouraged
when you hear the sound of thunder don't
you get too scared
just grab your Thunder buddies and say
these magic words
[ __ ] you thunder you can suck my dick